[Música]
en francés 24 es momento de hablar de
ciencia y tecnología soy Valentina
Torres Sánchez y es un gusto
acompañarlos iniciamos hablando de 19
porque la Organización Mundial de la
Salud alertó sobre la tendencia a
mezclar o combinar vacunas contra el
virus y aseguro que se trata de una
técnica peligrosa de la que faltan datos
y cuya decisión debe dejársele a los
expertos
Hay personas que están pensando en
mezclar y combinar vacunas hemos visto
muchas consultas de personas que dicen
que se han aplicado una y que planean
aplicarse otra sin embargo es una
tendencia un poco peligrosa la gente
está en una zona sin datos o pruebas en
lo que respecta a mezclar y combinar hay
datos limitados sobre estas prácticas
hay estudios en curso pero tenemos que
esperar
otra de las advertencias que emitió la
OMS tiene que ver con el uso de una
posible tercera dosis de un fármaco
inmunizante algunos mandatarios e
investigadores han señalado que una
dosis adicional de una vacuna serviría
para reforzar el efecto una vez que los
anticuerpos han empezado a disminuir sin
embargo el organismo aseguro que también
falta información sobre lo beneficioso o
perjudicial de esta práctica
nuestro grupo de expertos asesores
estratégicos definitivamente está
analizando cualquier evidencia que surja
sobre la necesidad y el uso de dosis de
refuerzo pero en este momento no hay
datos suficientes para señalar la
importancia de esas dosis y Menos ahora
que el suministro global es limitado es
importante repensarse algún país está
considerando aumentar y usar dosis de
refuerzo y en su lugar pensar en dar ese
suministro o compartir ese suministro
con países que ni siquiera han inoculado
a sus trabajadores de la salud
continuamos hablando de Kobe 19 pero
ahora nos centramos en la polémica que
rodea la vacuna janssen del laboratorio
Johnson and Johnson luego de que se que
podría haber un vínculo entre el fármaco
y el síndrome de guillain-barré una
enfermedad poco frecuente en la que el
sistema inmune del organismo ataca parte
del sistema nervioso periférico lo que
genera inflamación en los nervios que a
su vez produce debilidad muscular y
parálisis entre otros síntomas los
reportes llevaron a Johnson and Johnson
a emitir un comunicado en el que explica
que fueron reportados algunos casos del
síndrome de guillain-barré tras la
vacunación con el fármaco janssen la
mayoría ocurrió dentro de los 42 días
siguientes a la inmunización Pese a que
la posibilidad de que esto ocurra es muy
baja Johnson and Johnson modificó su
hoja informativa de la vacuna para
incluir información importante sobre
estos casos y sobre los signos y
síntomas del síndrome de guillain Barré
por su parte la administración de
alimentos y medicamentos de Estados
Unidos también actualizó su hoja de
información del medicamento y pidió a
las personas que busquen ayuda si tras
la inoculación se presentan síntomas
como sensación posibilidad u hormigueo
especialmente en las piernas o los
brazos que empeora y se extiende a otras
partes del cuerpo si hay dificultad para
caminar dificultad con los movimientos
faciales como hablar masticar o tragar
visión doble o incapacidad para mover
los ojos y dificultad para controlar la
vejiga o la función intestinal según lo
analizado se han presentado unos 100
casos en Estados Unidos pero recordemos
que casi 13 millones de personas han
recibido la única dosis que requiere
esta vacuna en esa nación por lo que de
todas formas se puede decir que el
número de eventos reportados es bajo sin
embargo 95 de los 100 casos requirieron
hospitalización y una persona falleció
cabe aclarar que los expertos han
explicado que son mucho mayores los
beneficios de recibir la vacuna a los
efectos secundarios que ocurren en una
proporción realmente baja cambiamos de
tema y continuamos con lasaña del
fundador del grupo Virgin Richard
branson que cumplió su sueño de llegar
el espacio en un avión fabricado por la
rama espacial de su compañía Virgin
Galáctica el multimillonario despegó
desde el desierto de Nuevo México con la
misión unity22 superó los 80 kilómetros
de altura experimentando unos minutos de
microgravedad y regresó con éxito a la
tierra la duración total del vuelo fue
de alrededor de una hora
fui un niño que miraba las Estrellas y
ahora soy un adulto en una nave espacial
mirando hacia nuestra bella tierra
a la próxima generación de soñadores si
nosotros podemos hacer esto imagínense
lo que podrán hacer ustedes
el primer ser humano que sale de la
tierra en su propia nave o avión y lo
hizo con cinco compañeros de tripulación
todos ellos al volver a nuestro planeta
recibieron una insignia que los acredita
como astronautas de la compañía Virgin
la vista te quita el aliento es decir no
hay duda de que somos Afortunados de
tener este planeta en el que todos
vivimos
todos tenemos que hacer todo lo que
podamos para ayudar a este increíble
planeta en el que vivimos y dedicaré el
resto de mi vida a hacerlo
y creo que otros que vayan al espacio
dedicarán su vida a este propósito
medios del mundo aseguraron que con este
hecho branson va a la cabeza de la
carrera espacial de los millonarios
junto con Jeff bezos fundador de Amazon
y con hilo musk fundador de spacex
además lasaña de branson marca un punto
clave para el turismo espacial a ustedes
Muchas gracias por acompañarme y
Recuerden que pueden ampliar este y
otros programas en nuestra web
france24.com
[Música]